un carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
la razón de las artes se encuentra en el
bulevar de la croacia el para este
número especial desde el festival de
cine de cannes festival que reúne por
estos días a la crema y nata del séptimo
arte mundial
[Música]
les hablaremos de la cinta que sacudió
al actual dt en 2022 o crímenes del
futuro del canadiense david cronenberg
una cinta de ciencia ficción
protagonizada por viggo mortensen como
siempre cannes permitió un desfile de
estrellas figuras de hollywood como
julia roberts o tom cruise se dejaron
ver para el júbilo de los fanáticos el
veterano director chileno patricio
guzmán recibió una ovación en cannes por
su último documental mi país imaginario
en el que guzmán registró el estallido
social de 2019 en chile- y fuimos al
encuentro del público del festival de
cannes fanáticos amantes del cine y
curiosos muy numerosos como siempre
sobre el aqua set
[Música]
el festival de cine de cannes es uno de
los más grandes y reconocidos del mundo
21 películas han formado parte este año
de la competencia pero sólo una se
llevará la palma de oro y este año hemos
visto drama comedia y hasta una fantasía
animal pero una cinta sacudió a la
casete con una historia de ciencia
ficción y terror corporal que les
comentamos en 321
qué
y si en un futuro no tan lejano los
seres humanos pudieran controlar su
cuerpo y crear órganos a su antojo esa
es la interrogante que plantea el
canadiense david cronenberg en su última
película crímenes del futuro el polémico
director de cine de 79 años quien ya
había acudido a cannes en
1996 con crack concurre por la palma de
oro con esta película gore erótica y
visceral sobre un dúo de artistas que se
dedica a la ablación de órganos en
público david cronenberg habla aquí de
tecnología y de mutaciones pero también
sobre la contaminación de la naturaleza
con plástico
hace 20 años nadie hablaba de los micro
plásticos y ahora sabemos que 80% de las
personas en el mundo tienen partículas
plásticas en su cuerpo hay científicos
estudiando cómo crear plásticos que se
puedan comer de hecho ya hay animales
que pueden comerlos de eso trata la
película
crímenes del futuro cuenta con la
actuación de viggo mortensen el papel de
un artista radical que hace espectáculos
basado en la extirpación de órganos
fabricados en su cuerpo
y adiós
a la tecnología cuando se habla de arte
hay obras reales y ahora tenemos también
la tecnología y la imaginación sobre el
futuro el ser humano siempre ha vivido
en tensión gente el deseo de inventar o
de experimentar cosas nuevas y el miedo
de lo que pueda crear el arte puede ser
tener un objetivo y a la vez generar
represión o conducir a la rebelión
creadora y creo que eso es precisamente
lo que david hace como director de cine
escritor o intelectual y en lo que hacen
acá pricit en ser en esta peli que se
saque la zona
a continuación lo mejor y lo más
destacado de esta edición número 75 del
festival de cine de cannes
pero en 2022 la cual se libró con la
presencia de tom cruise quien vino para
el estreno del nuevo top gun maverick
hacía 30 años que el actor
estadounidense no se dejaba ver en el
certamen de la riviera francesa que le
reservó una calurosa acogida una palma
de oro de honor y el homenaje desde los
cielos de la patrulla
la alfombra roja también fue el
escenario para la sorpresiva protesta de
una activista feminista que buscaba
denunciar la violación de las mujeres
ucranianas por parte del ejército ruso
durante la invasión a ucrania guerra en
ucrania que también fue denunciada por
el director de cine ruso kirill
serebrennikov un conocido opositor al
kremlin en la competencia por la palma
de oro con su película la esposa de
tchaikovsky justo antes de la proyección
del documental y póster feminista
activistas de la cinta encendieron
granadas de humo negro en la alfombra
roja y extendieron un largo cartel con
los nombres de las 129 víctimas
francesas de feminicidio del último año
el festival de cannes es durante 12 días
el epicentro del séptimo arte mundial
con estrellas engalanadas con sus
mejores trajes y derroche de
extravagancia la francesa isabelle
huppert caminó con un extraño vestido
verde mientras que sharon ston y julia
roberts suscitaron largos aplausos de
los fanáticos que se agolparon en el
palacio de los festivales
el festival de cine de cannes se acogió
una vez más al director chileno radicado
en francia- patricio guzmán quien trajo
a cannes su último documental mi país
imaginario presentado en las sesiones
especiales un trabajo en el que guzmán
puso su objetivo en las protestas
masivas que tuvieron lugar en chile- en
[Aplausos]
[Música]
de la violencia
[Aplausos]
fue tan violento el estallido y tan
notorio que inmediatamente pensé hay que
ir allí a filmar porque lo que se está
produciendo es una explosión social y
esto comenzó en el metro y poco a poco a
lo largo de la semana se extendió a toda
una clase media grande reunimos material
de archivo y comenzamos a montar un poco
y al cabo de algunos meses fuimos y
empezamos a rodar en el mismo lugar y
era apasionante porque no hay una cosa
hermosa en el documental es cuando las
masas se mueven cuando una corriente de
opinión sale a la calle y se mueve la
ciudad entera eso es lo mejor que puede
pasar y así empezamos a afirmar usted
aborda en esta película un fenómeno que
le dio la vuelta al mundo y que
entristeció a mucha gente y es el la
pérdida de los ojos de los jóvenes de
los estudiantes de las personas que
estaban en la calle a manos de la
policía
es decir que protestar en chile le costó
el ojo de la cara a mucha gente
y la policía es muy violenta dispara al
cuerpo dispara de cerca balas
lagrimógenas que son muy duras y a los
ojos al principio eran muy brutales
después bajaron un poco la violencia
cuando vieron tantos heridos pero se
quedó mucha gente sino josé fue una
represión brutal
que no se puede curar o sea la gente
quedó muerta o ciega insólito y usted
puso su objetivo también en otra
temática muy importante actualmente
chile y es la lucha de las mujeres la
posición de las mujeres el hecho de que
ellas hayan salido también a protestar
por sus derechos por las condiciones de
vida que hay en chile bueno casi todas
las entrevistas son mujeres que hablan
mejor son más claras tienen argumentos
son más luchadoras están organizadas por
lo tanto tú dices bueno aquí es de cajón
hay que entrevistar a las mujeres los
hombres están ahí ayudan apoyan etcétera
pero la mujer es la que organiza la
resistencia la que argumenta la que
tiene razones para protestar eso en
chile no es actual siempre la mujer ha
sido más activa que el hombre
políticamente y es estupendo no hay
ningún hombre en la película y otro
lugar donde las mujeres han puesto sus
dos pies sus dos manos su cabeza su
pensamiento es en esa asamblea
constituyente que se ha instalado para
escribir una nueva carta magna en chile
y allí también las mujeres han puesto su
contribución si en esa asamblea como tú
dices hay muchas mujeres pero es mixta
digamos hay hombres y mujeres que al
igual es una institución que discute
analiza busca y trata de encontrar
qué argumentos debería tener la nueva
constitución y creo que esta
constitución finalmente será aprobada
por la mayoría no es seguro pero es una
posibilidad interesante es muy bueno
porque hay que cambiar la constitución
de ese país en la constitución antigua
el líder de la dictadura militar
exactamente constitución de pinochet
limitada que no ha dejado que el país se
desarrolla democráticamente que continúa
una especie de medianía en manos de las
grandes empresas que explotan el pueblo
chileno y ahora hay una posibilidad de
volver a una normalidad relativa
vamos a ver qué pasa si tu company en la
constitución de francia y la de chile es
increíble parecen dos planetas patricio
guzmán después de haber hecho esta
película qué visión tiene usted del
chile que no ha abandonado nunca el
chile actual
bueno es un país difícil complicado con
muchos problemas en el norte en el sur
un país que no ha solucionado los
problemas durante años y años nadie ha
hecho nada realmente por ese país ni
desde el punto de vista de clase media
ni del punto de vista de los negocios ni
del punto de vista de las empresas ni
desde el punto de vista de las regiones
es un país abandonado mal mal gobernado
mediocremente gobernado entonces ahora
hay que volver a retomar todo y empezar
de nuevo va a costar y va a costar un
poco muchísimas gracias patricia guzmán
gracias a ti por tus preguntas
no
el festival de cine de cannes proyecta
más de 100 películas venidas de todo el
mundo una verdadera fiesta del séptimo
arte mundial que atrae a fanáticos ya
curiosos a la riviera francesa nos lo
cuenta melissa barra
cannes es una fiesta de cine y una
pasarela a cielo abierto
diseñadores de fama mundial o modistas
independientes envían a sus embajadoras
a la alfombra roja para lucir sus
últimas creaciones durante años
celebridades y modelos tuvieron ese
privilegio hoy lo tienen chicas y chicos
comunes convertidos en estrellas de las
redes sociales
a unos metros de ahí estudiantes y
anónimos cinéfilos aguardan a la entrada
del palacio de festivales a la espera de
que algún participante generoso les
regale una invitación es el caso de
melissa nazis y félix fui pintando
llegamos una hora pidiendo boletos hay
que estar en el lugar adecuado
siempre logro tener uno todavía quedan
30 minutos antes de la proyección tengo
fe
son las veces que no he podido encontrar
en nuestros nueve años si funciona si no
no lo haría
[Música]
el festival de cannes se vive dentro de
sus salas de cine pero también afuera en
la cual sets con los cientos de fans que
cada día se amontonan frente a la
alfombra roja con la ilusión de obtener
de sus estrellas favoritas una sonrisa
un autógrafo o hasta un self y reservan
su puesto con días de antelación
colocando taburetes y escaleras a lo
largo del recorrido los apodan de hecho
el clan de las escaleras martín lleva 10
años en cannes
[Aplausos]
y llega a los autos y empieza a todo con
la música el ambiente de las estrellas
se bajan de la utilizamos cantamos les
tomamos fotos en magnífico
moscú y mis amores cabo solo mi escalera
la personal y se puso una imagen de
túnez cruzó con su avión de combate para
que lo hubiese siente alagado director
white flag tbilisi
[Aplausos]
gracias melisa barra y el palacio de los
festivales se llenó de niños este año
con el estreno de la cinta francesa de
dibujos animados lópez y nicolás con
ellos despedimos este carrusel de las
artes que les presentamos desde el
festival de cannes y le damos cita para
la próxima semana jajaja
[Aplausos]
yo estoy aquí en vigor en
pues escribo un bajón físico para ganar
[Música]
sí ah
e
[Música]
ah
venid
[Música]
cualquier golpe algo luego de repente
d
[Música]